hey everyone and welcome back to the
things today we're going to show you
some of our favorite cartoon characters
who've been spotted in real life these
Disney doppelgangers and cartoon
copycats are totally mind-blowing you
won't believe which major pop star bears
a striking resemblance to a certain
classic Disney cartoon character watch
until the end to find out who it is
Despicable Me Agnes Agnes is the spunky
kid with a pony tail on top of her head
that looks like an exclamation point she
loves fluffy unicorns and gummy bear
houses she's sweet imaginative and as
stolen grooves heart if only she were a
real person well we found her and here
she is this kid totally captures the
essence of Agnes she's got the
expressive ponytail the hopeful eyes and
the spunky pose if Agnes were a real kid
we have to wonder who she would be
friends with it would probably be our
next character on the list they're
almost the same age and they have this
same affinity for monstrous characters
we're talking of course about boo from
monsters Inc who is a little girl with a
lot of courage she may be small but
she's got a powerful voice and even more
powerful laugh she's a little younger
than Agnes but we think they would still
be friends in real life this little girl
looks exactly like the cartoon character
boo just like human Agnes boo has
excited little pigtails that convey her
personality she loves adventures with
unlikely friends and she believes in
magical creatures there's no telling
what would happen if boo and Agnes got
together but we're pretty sure that they
would give the monster world a run for
their money
lilo from lilo and stitch lilo is a
six-year-old girl from Hawaii with a
rather odd friend she has long black
hair animist devious smile while she's
normally wearing a red and green muumuu
she has also been seen wearing a red and
green hula costume well there's a human
version of our favorite Hawaiian Disney
cartoon character and we can't believe
our eyes this girl looks exactly like
lilo from her long black hair to that
mischievous grin on her face she's
wearing the exact same costume as the
lilo war during the luau scene in the
movie she probably even has the same
hula moves The Incredibles violet
cosplay erm are grey
went
a convention with her Incredibles game
on point she looks exactly like violet
from The Incredibles movie violet it's
the shy and quiet teenage girl who comes
from a family of supers she has the
ability to make herself invisible and
create force fields she has a long black
hair and curious eyes violet and her
family all wear a similiar super suit
it's a red leotard with a black mask
when she's not fighting with her brother
she's saving the city from the latest
evil villain and speaking of her brother
we found his real-life look-alike - -
from The Incredibles
we can't have violet without
representing her brother - to - is a
total troublemaker he loves to show off
his super abilities even though his
parents have asked him to keep them on
the down low this kid totally nailed
Dash's look his pose is the biggest
indicator of his superpower abilities
he's ready to fight bad guys with his
incredible family but when he's not
fighting bad guys who does he hang out
with he'll need fellow troublemaker kids
who understand his need to shake things
up a bit and who better than this
following character Darla from Finding
Nemo Darla is the stuff of nightmares
she loves fish but has a bit of an
impulse control problem she won't stop
shaking fish bags and she bangs on the
glass of the fish tank way too hard but
it's all because she can't contain her
excitement when she's in the presence of
her swimming friends we found this human
version of Darla and she is just as
terrifying as the cartoon we hope that
Little Nemo is going to make it out of
that bag
rustle from us Russell is a wilderness
explorer with a zest for adventure and a
fascination with wildlife with the help
of mr. Fredricksen Russell saves a
strange bird named Kevin who is actually
a lady bird with a bunch of babies well
if there was a look-alike contest this
kid totally nailed it
he's even got this - with all the merit
badges sewn on this little guy looks
like he's ready for anything
he's got the seem enthusiastic energy as
the cartoon Russell can we get this kid
a merit badge for his masterful cartoon
character impersonation who wouldn't
want to go exploring unknown regions
with Russell 2.0 we can think of another
character who likes to go beyond the
city borders Cindy Lou who from
the Grinch Stole Christmas do you
remember the classic cartoon version of
dr. Seuss's How the Grinch Stole
Christmas the Grinch is story has been
reimagined multiple times over the last
few decades but one thing that has
remained constant throughout the stories
is lovely little Cindy Lou Who she's the
curious child who sees the good in the
Grinch even when everyone else only sees
a smelly hairy grumpy dude
well we found Cindy Lou who in real life
she's got the seem innocent blue eyes
the same inquisitive bows in her hair
and the same cheerful Hope beaming from
her little face pickup from How to Train
Your Dragon hiccup horrendous hat off
the third is the determined but scrawny
Viking kid whose love for the Dragon
race changed everything even though he's
small and a bit clumsy he does his best
to fit in among the others in his Viking
village hiccup is highly intelligent he
has a gift for creating inventions like
the prosthetic tail he made for
toothless this cosplayer looks exactly
like hiccup he's got the same windblown
hair and riding armor as his cartoon
counterpart he looks like he's ready for
his next adventure in this guy the only
thing missing in this picture is his
Night Fury friend beaver pan more than
one celebrity mag has pointed out the
similarities between Disney's animated
version of Peter Pan and pop star Justin
Bieber when you think about it the
resemblance doesn't stop with just his
physical appearance peter is a rowdy
immature boy who never grows up flies
all over to magical places and loves a
girl who decided to grow up sound
familiar
when you look at side-by-side pictures
it's pretty undeniable yes the same
expressive eyebrows and boyish grin as
the free-spirited animated character
let's just hope he doesn't have to fight
too many real-life pirates which
look-alike was your favorite do you
think Justin Bieber looks like Peter Pan
sound off in the comments below
and that's it for now thanks for
watching the things if you love these
cartoon characters as much as we do be
sure to subscribe to our channel and
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time
[Music]